thank you to both rocket money and
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people citizens of the reject Nation
it's me Tara Erikson and this
is I Greg
ala introducing me I forgot yeah yeah
yeah anyway that's that guy listen you
guys voted whether we were going to
watch Percy Jackson or Lucy and you guys
voted on this Percy Jackson that's what
we're watching today y we love you guys
also don't forget to leave a like a
comment ring the bell ring the
bell ring the bell well you know what's
weird I I'm surprised people voted for
this because book readers really didn't
like this movie oh really I know nothing
about the movie or the book I know I'm
like who is Percy and why is his last
name Jackson I'm on the exact same page
as you I have no clue about any of the
story I haven't even seen the trailer
for The the Disney Plus show so I'm like
I don't know why people like this movie
or don't like it but we're going to
judge it just off the movie and I'm
going to judge him for having two first
names first and Jackson get out okay now
listen thanks to pre for helping us edit
down these videos guys if you haven't
been to the real reject Nation Shop nope
it's reject naations shop.com get a
t-shirt show them the T-shirt Greg just
do it come on now thanks dear get it in
there do the thing also we call you
super sexy if you join patreon super
sexy is like cool you can sing it with
your own coffee well it's a whole like
PR Jack with me and cooker GRE and John
offer exclusive highlights and watch
alongs over there on patreon so get on
get with it if you know what's good for
you should we get started we should get
started okay let's do
[Music]
it you know I met the person who plays
Percy Jackson Logan lurman you did nice
gentle man did you tell him hey I've
never watched anything you've done yeah
I didn't watch your biggest
movie oh Chris
Columbus he did pixels
oh oh The Lightning Thief that looks
awesome I want to be in a
stormm it doesn't storm out here in La
yeah what a
[Laughter]
[Music]
bummer
whoa who aquam
man those are some fascinating visual
effects Aqua
monster oh is he like faidon is that the
oh yeah the water the water guy like
little mermaid's
dad
oh oh my God he's blending in with
normal society cool and all I had to do
was let a little water go he did the
first Harry Potter movie this director
oh Chris Columbus right
yeah Zeus Zeus oh Sean Bean wait is that
a a racist term CH
Bean totally got his name wrong my God
we got to mute that
now besided it's been many years what do
you see
thunderclouds but no lightning who's
that stolen you think I took it
omnipotence has blinded you brother
those American flags fake we are
forbidden from stealing each other's
Powers but our children aren't I haven't
seen him since he was a baby he doesn't
know me or even know who he is because
of you Lightning Thief yeah okay I want
to steal lightning he must return the
Bol to me in 14 days by midnight night
on the summer solstice 14 days is a
decent amount of time so the son it must
be Percy Jackson or there will be war
[Music]
w I don't know if he needs the lightning
I mean he just blew right through a
concrete door it looks
like guys are destroying New York
landmarks for your own scuffles
wa and and and they answered my question
about destroying
places and the Olympians the Lightning
Thief okay so it's play
on I love him that's that's Logan lurman
I just when people say names I nod and I
go aha but you have to show me a picture
he must be the son yeah who stole the
[Music]
lightning this actually an amazing shot
is he really underwater I'm like are you
holding your breath for that long yeah
is he really underwat good job buddy no
he'd be dead by now right I wonder if
they like slowed it down or if it's just
a visual attack
shot maybe he really knows how oh that
was dope was that a hidden cut that must
have been that was cool first SE Jackson
as a beast how long was that 7 Minutes 7
minutes that's nothing how do you do it
I just like being
water this one place I can think oh he
doesn't realize he's like the son of a
God that he's son of Poseidon I'm Miss
DDS your substitute English teacher
would someone please explain what
Shakespeare was trying to convey in this
line from aelo let me go to chat gbt and
I'll tell you
[Music]
well
uh what is oh he's dislexic he's chat
gbt oh he's dyslexic I'm sorry I don't
know I thought he was deciphering oh my
God I think he's just dyslexic hey Mom
how was school today Catherine Kaner I
like her she's an elf dyslexia thing is
getting worse oh why do you think that
cuz he can't read maybe it's the ADHD
you know I thought this school was
supposed to make things better Percy I
know how hard this is for you so he's
half human hi
Gabe where's my beer oh I recognize that
voice it's in the fridge it's supposed
to magically float from the ice box and
into my hand oh I would knock him
out
oh come on man you have to do that right
here show some respect right that's my
mom right there yeah dude Yo Joe pelana
a smack him around would you he's been
good to us Percy in ways you just you
don't understand you're right I don't
understand I don't get oh my God I hope
by the end of the movie we realize that
he's not really that abusive of a guy
that he's taken on a responsibility to
care for we just don't know Prodigy boy
yeah but how can he take care of them if
he can't hold down a job G because my
first thought was he gives them money he
doesn't cuz he doesn't have a job Greek
and Roman galleries oh this is going to
connect to Percy Jackson's backstory and
Poseidon is it Poseidon I don't know if
it's Poseidon everything is about to
change
pery everything is about to
change dad I love that cliche of the bus
in front of the ghost they vanish with
it I always imagine the character just
running three of the brothers Zeus
posidon it is
Poseidon they attain Power by over Pier
broen cronis chopping him into little
pieces the three guards have been Rivals
ever since that teacher's got her eye on
him on several occasions they would come
down to earth and um hook
up they would hook up with Mortals nice
he's one of them half God
half human oh can anyone tell me what
they were called oh I know the word
other than
Supernatural uh oh my God I forgot it
Waterman
no and a god a human and a God that God
exactly no oh what I was thinking of a
totally different word I'll give you a
hint you have something in common he is
a chosen
one
oh pus
Percy
percus direct it's not dyslexia it's a
gift so dyslexia people can just read
Greek all over the place that's the
implication
yeah first
yes we need to
talk okay she knows I don't think she's
just a regular substitute teacher okay
she's from the water too huh oh she's
some type of
Olympian so did I do something
wrong oh oh she like a bird I heard
Wings where is it oh w w how did you get
up
there oh my God what is
happening this is so unexpected you
stole the lightning bolt I don't know
you're talking about give it to
me give it to me
oh Jesus oh my
God release him oh my God he's something
too I swear I'll tear you to
pieces so like everyone's got their eye
on
Percy did that really just happened a
fury concealed in our school I should
have known who who does his friend know
he must know because he was at the pool
with him and was like hey that's why
you're yeah 7 Minute Man he's no longer
secure here okay where should be moving
oh A take this to defend yourself
it's a powerful weapon only use it in
times of severe distress the hell is
that it's a pen this is a pen take him
to his mother and don't let him out of
your sight okay maybe it's filled with
vodka so his whole life he's been
surrounded by people just watching over
him you would think all that noise in
there would have caused more people to
be like what's going on where did our
teacher
go Sally more
beer I got this guy look we got to talk
can't you see she's servicing me in my
friends don't talk about my mom like
that you baldheaded
freak what Cal
down oh hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
where are you taking me what is this
camp for really special people am I
crazy or something Percy this is about
your father
decided we got it right that time cuz we
knew your father was unlike any guy I'd
ever seen he was just dazzling he was
massive when he came out of the
water we were really in love Percy and
then you came along and then it it was
just perfect perfect Percy he looks like
Zach afron from certain shots he does
leaving you it was probably the most
difficult thing he ever did so we
assigned a bunch of people to watch over
here oh so Zeus is a bad
guy uh yeah did you see that monster
yeah Sor watch
out
whoa they just killed a cow go are you
right is it me or is it raining cows
we're not even 20 minutes in this movie
Cuts past all
[Laughter]
you we got a bunch of Lord
against my job W who who what I'm half
goat that's why he walks like
that am I not supposed to be enjoying
this movie because I really
am how does he get changed for PE he's
got HBS what fascin they had they had to
do the reveal at night to to mask it in
the visual effect
wa that's some pretty good effects
though that looks awesome pretty good
effect that's very sad about the car
though
here well this is a fun set and
fancy oh see Half Blood Half Blood
Prince
ooh oh what are you doing this is as far
as I can go you're human she's not
allowed I'm not leaving without you you
have to you're meant
to
oh Bye Mom holy kill her kill her
before his us what can I do use the pen
what use B's pen and click it he's like
a video game helper character wo cool oh
okay I think she's
gone oh my God he knows how to front
[Laughter]
roll you got this
Percy are you
okay oh oh wow he did it by
accident behind
you
whoa
day one on the job Percy Jackson be
taking to that monsters Beast
nice where am I what is this place the
infirmary been unconscious for 3 days
three days what do you remember a
monster my mom was there well you were
there too but you were some weird hybrid
man goat thing
whoa that's hot all of it was real my
mom's gone I try man I really do frankly
I'm just a junior protector I don't have
my horns yet you think by the end of the
movie he's going to get his horns he
will I certainly hope so he'll move from
Junior to senior protector and then
he'll go kill his stepdad this is Camp
Half Half meaning what I think you know
half meaning half mortal half gu oh guys
watch the arrows newcomer oh so he's
just a regular amongst them they're all
half Bloods remember Mr Bruner said
Sometimes they come down to earth and
they fall in love with Mortals and then
they have kids he was giving that
Exposition exactly at the right time
you're a demig God two points to Percy
Jackson y those effects are not bad
they're very good you mean his legs yeah
yeah it's a place where you learn to
harness your powers you'll train to
become leaders Warriors and heroes this
looks like professional laring or just
gymnastics when you try to read the
words Flo off the page right that's
because your brain's hardwired for
ancient Greek not English that called it
that's what's happening with us that's
that's what happen that's why we're can
read that's why we can't read your
impulsive Percy those are your natural
battle reflexes man they kept you alive
in your fight what does this movie say
about mental
health your blood is
special it's the blood of a God we have
the blood of gods Terra demig Gods we
are which is why were also mentally ill
this movie gives hope to everyone
diagnosed with ADHD and dyslexia and
dyslexia
yeah love
interest you can tell by the way the
frame rate changes I think it's really
just that she's a hot red head what's
her
name Annabeth daughter of Athena the
goddess of wisdom
nice oh that's Alexandra didario look at
her
this movie's old yeah they look so young
okay you were like 40 when it came out
yeah the mcira Centaur what are those
things the
Centaur wait a minute is that Mr Bruner
oh my God he's a centaur I like how they
disguise themselves as people with
disabilities
yeah I'm known as Chiron like did he
hide all that in a wheelchair barely
he's tucked it in I apologize for hiding
My True Form but I needed to keep an eye
on you I hope you'll forgive me you see
him out of breath man he hasn't been a
he was just running around the lake I
like that attention to detail though
like got to be huffing and puffing a
little bit
man go over there oh my goodness there
diety if they're played by adults go
over there you guys got a lot of
catching up to do their mother's the
goddess of love so you know where that
leads
[Laughter]
welcome home your father built this for
you this little
Shack I think they just film this in
Canada seems he got some weight through
it giant fork just like little mermaid's
dad head a tried it my father's beside
god of the seas why didn't anybody tell
me it was for your own s safety it's
exceedingly rare for a child to be born
to one of the big
three who am I threatening Poseidon's
Brothers Zeus and Hades that's why your
mother married your stepfather okay his
pungent odor masked the smell of your
blood oh my God that's hilarious cuz of
his oh my God there's other he smells
like voice they could have got
about it it's
hilarious you could have just doused
yourself and
gasoline Zeus's bolt is the most
powerful weapon ever created and if it's
not returned by the summer solers in 10
days there will be a war this is your
problem all right not mine this is about
your world not mine this is about all
worlds homeboy adjusted to this world
really well yeah and fairly quickly what
can we do I want to take you to Olympus
convince Seuss of your innocence will
that work someone's using you to start a
war what are we doing here let's go now
first we must train now other than being
a centaur what is there like a power a
centaur has they're magical but like the
are like powerful warriors I don't know
anything about Centaur other than
they're half humans half horses you know
Centaur effects aren't too bad on Pierce
broen actually do you think there was
another guy back there with their legs
yeah probably in a green I got to play
Pierce broen's ass on
IMDb This is py Jackson and he's going
to need a team we'll take
them I'm Luke I know this guy son of
Hermes and Camp leader where's your
helmet no one gave me one Kiren you
still got your wheelchair kids going to
need it this feels like a very expensive
Disney Channel
movie
yeah anybody got an extra helmet please
pass it
up oh my gosh she she's giv him the look
welcome to the blue soldiers my friend
everyone in position for capture the
flag first team to capture the enemy's
Banner wins steady
steady now wa what a
shot that's fun it's like Capture the
Flag but with swords and stuff
yeah I always do appreciate the feeling
of actual costumes and real extras wa
that that's a cool
shot first I know where the flag's at
come on keep your eyes open don't get
killed so train with actual swords what
if someone actually got
killed or sliced
oh oh my goodness I'm coming buddy I'm
coming sons of Ares Watch Out w that's a
sword that's a sword it's ADR or
something else oh you guys take Camp way
too seriously go
how is Percy Jackson keeping up oh she
just like naturally good with the sword
go look for the flag how did I just do
that I don't know it's in your blood
Half Blood this script requires you to
survive what are you doing why are you
not capturing the
flag we do need to get to a point where
Percy earns stuff though instead of yeah
instead of just being working for him
yeah just be lucking out all the time
maybe this is the point where he learns
a lesson he's going to fight the girl oh
and she's going to kick his
butt who whoa whoa did you really think
it would be that easy no this movie is
not predictable at all my mother is
goddess of wisdom and battle strategy
she's like Wonder Woman I always win
okay I always lose maybe we're both
wrong do you always
lose dang girl okay heck yeah he was
flirting with you man he really liked
you and now you cut his
face okay KY should we get in there and
stop him she's killing him man you got
to be kidding this is the best part
why o dude he is getting his ass handed
to I've been waiting for this to happen
learn your
lesson
I like how they made her looking away
and she had let hot girl turn around
yeah yeah one day hot girl turn around
you'll achieve it one day Tera yeah hot
girl turn around then they'll go no we
need somebody else rise get to the water
heal by the water go swimming it's in
your blood will give you power the
element of Life
H2O oh it's like healing I bet for him
yeah that's what I've been trying to say
over your I mean I heard you but I was
like oh is it just going to happen that
quick it is okay yeah Percy Jackson
you're unstoppable man jum jump in come
on just go for a little swim
swim as long as he's always by the water
he'll be all right just carry a little
canteen with him he'll be
fine
I've got a question what if he like cut
his hand and then he washed it in the
[Laughter]
sink then it would
[Music]
heal wow this dude is a Mary
Sue will you go out with me I guess I
don't always lose
[Music]
they're a match made in Love and
War oh nice cool I give her a kiss out
just make out in front of everyone
guys oh my God she looks turned on she
wants him I mean why wouldn't you want
him so bad right now dating the
lottery I don't want the lottery
more
[Applause]
how quickly that went does make me feel
like it's like a Disney TV movie but
it's just cuz he didn't go through much
yet but maybe he will I don't care I'm
having too much fun with this movie oh
it's great it's really fun the movie is
awesome that did just happen quick
though it's completely like it's really
cheesy but it's really fun it's really
fun Hey Percy um we're having party at
our place later and we would really love
it if you came oh ladies ladies
please I would love to come too to the
party thanks for inviting me ladies Beat
It N oh Pierce them with his Jackson you
know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying oh I
know what you're saying I get a sense
that you don't like me very much it's
possible I mean our parents hate each
other her dad's Zeus I definitely have
strong feelings for you I just haven't
decided if they're positive or negative
yet I hope they lean positive well you
let me know and you figure it out
they'll be the first and Hell Jackson
you up this is amazing that Reflection
from the glasses was awesome I love them
together oh sweet that looks cool scary
oh my gosh that's so big that is a demon
entity Percy Jackson show
yourself oh my gosh show yourself buddy
Percy stop flirting get in
there stay back all right let's see what
the Centaur can do Percy Jackson bring
me the bolt he doesn't know what the
bolt is yet right he doesn't have the
bolt he doesn't no he's Bol in him and I
will exch change it for your
mother oh prick my mother's gone your
mother is still alive I said the minur
to abduct her I like this design this
guy's got to brush his teeth yes he
does a the mom's just suffering
Mercy what have you done with my
mother that's an odd line delivery but
I'm okay with
[Music]
it no say
be BR then did not look
comfortable no he's like he's like the
oh man get your watch get there would
you when he finds out you don't have the
bolt We'll Kill You Andel my life this
is her only chance why they have to
shoot Pierce BR so
closely poor Pierce once you convince
him of your innocence we will do
everything in our power to bring back
this movie has paced just fast enough
for me to keep up with what's going on
and to ignore the flaws yeah I love it
it's my kind of
movie no no I'm going alone no I'm
coming with you no you're being followed
I a my black friend and my hot
girlfriend let's
go one small victory and you're ready to
fight Hades oh double te really you two
uh oh God my mother is still alive I'm
going to get her back from the
underworld look man I can't let you do
this okay I'm not asking for your
permission God damn it Ron and Hermione
you better get your together if
you're going to hang out Harry this is
something I have to do on my own yeah
well we weren't asking for your
permission today you tried to kill me
now you want to defend me it wasn't real
that was just training really all that
slashing I've grown up here I've only
been in the outside world a couple of
times and I've never had the chance to
go on an actual Quest until now you've
won one battle and I've won hundreds
you're going to need my experience yeah
but he like he whooped every he whooped
everyone's ass yeah but it's not cuz he
earned it it's just cuz he is a son of
the top three gods and maybe she her dad
is top three I don't know who knows how
to get to the underworld I think I know
someone who
might
Luke hey handsome mhm welcome to the
modern world cool does he have a toilet
why do we need to know that Gregory the
modern world he has nature your dad is
the messenger of the Gods one of the
only ones who's gotten in and out of the
underworld ah my dad's a jerk I've never
met him that's because all gods are the
same selfish they only care about
themselves hey don't talk about me like
that but I once broke into my dad's
house got some cool stuff show us the
toilet he goes poop in nature in the
tree that's like right there I know I
would never want to hang out with them
he pees and poops in that tree right
behind that sheet next to the centaurs
then he burns
it w cool
now I've seen everything has hundreds of
these little
guys won't even miss them look
underneath the other one yeah but
they're cool cuz they're convert yeah so
they're like modern and hip stylish
people have gone to the underworld
before without having to be dead
Hercules did it orus did it my dad does
it all the time getting in is the easy
part getting out that's tricky look how
like cool and modern day every one of
these kids are they're like adults but
they're not this is a map to pran's
pearls you mean hades's wife yeah he
forced her to marry him needless to say
she hates it there he's a weirdo so she
has um secret visitors oh Hades wife be
having some fun these pearls they
provide a quick escape from the
underworld so how do the pearls work you
take a pearl you step on it you crush it
visualize where you want to be taken H
now there's three pearls in the United
States this map will guide you there
right here is your first location
McGuffin let's go antm's Garden in
Emporium New Jersey the map will show
you the next one and the next one and
then you're off to Hades oh my God
scavenger hunt you guys might need some
extra protection a dis this guy's got
everything my favorite Shield you might
want to take a step back why is he so
nice I don't trust him I feel like he's
got to some he's like been so nice since
the top I don't trust him I don't trust
him he's too nce feel like he's leading
the lightning Bol awayce I know I think
he's a plant this place definitely needs
an Extreme Makeover what if you just
gave him like specific jeans to wear
then he wouldn't need to like have the
crutches right right but then he'd have
to have big yeah right right well okay
that's nasty for oh maybe it's cuz he
walks he walks where when he's a goat so
he has to that's like a it's the throw
off descent right okay sure it's
Justified I feel like he can formulate
some type of he like walks weird so then
those those just he does when he's a
goat I swear he could just have like he
could say he's got like some type of
condition that's what they all do gold
drmas that means we're on the right
track how are we going to find the Pearl
in this place sing it to you check
everything good idea I'm going to go
this way I'm going go this
way I don't know why that made me laugh
they're like it's so small and you're
like I'm going to go this way what a
convoluted
adventure oh that's lit Soph we stopped
the direction my poor husband help help
me please help me this a trap don't fall
for the
bait too
late hey it looks like the Satan guy no
those are the horns he wants to achieve
I think he's just like my uncle fan yeah
oh yeah got the moan the same
place I like the horror Vibes Uncle F
was killed by pe it it togethera oh the
counter in
Medusa don't don't look at Medusa
oh they're all stoned please we have to
leave before she finds us she turn my
husband is Stone do you know Medusa no
no well you will they turns people to
Stone listen where are we we're in
Medusa's
layer a b we're lost we'll never it's
like a Cinematic Universe
movie oh my God what modern day touches
it's so hardening to to have such young
visitors let's see your hair oh yeah she
has a hair of snakes now I'm with it
daughter of Athena how do you know me
you have such beautiful hair oh it is
pretty nice and thick and yeah very
distinct I guess I once had hair like
that desired by many sutors but that all
changed because of your mother the woman
who cursed me she's got like the black
leather Matrix thing going on who turned
me love it into a snake Snakehead
lady cool ew and their mouths open and
stuff I hope you find my
eye oh it's Uma Thurman duh I didn't you
recognize her right away yes that's why
I went oh her how can you not I had no
idea that was my God Gregory he doesn't
know what is he even doing here you
know why why why are you doing it oh can
she hypnotize
them oh that's cool wait why did the
lady look lady can Medusa also hypnotize
she said some weird thing the lady
opened her eyes why we supposed to fight
something we can't look at we can look
at a reflection check this out all right
good idea smart you make a wonderful
addition to my
collection oh no no I love it this this
feels like a a teenager wrote
it but I like it it say this like Spirit
of a teenager writing it don't look
annabet don't open your
eyes who's
that another Dam God e oh the the
close-ups on it are are gross were they
protrude out of her skull or really
gross I mean it looks super freaking
fake but that's not age well
overall son of
posidon I used to date your daddy
oh oh dude oh all these you're crushing
all your friends
Medusa sure come on let's go I there's I
guess there's no process reversing the
back also he broke the arm part and she
just took her hand out of the hand uh
just a quick note that didn't make sense
so she could have just taken it off she
could have
just all you have to
do she does have a weird hypnotizing
thing cuz he's almost going to do
it wa wao watch out for the overkill all
right feel like if you just keep a blade
close enough to you you could just stab
her in the gut right yeah cuz she has to
get if she if she gets that close to you
she's been getting close to all of
them there you go yeah just get
her what do you do size her head off oh
okay cool it's cool to open up your eyes
and be hey it's me Percy yeah I'm a star
of the show
here we should take it with us uh why
why would you do that if you open the
eyes they still work Co Dead or Alive y
you never know when something like that
might come in handy maybe towards the
end when you're fighting the ultimate
bad guy come on man just take off your
jacket we'll wrap it up until we get
some ice oh why why I got to take off my
jacket because you're the protector oh
wow way to push her around the the black
guy this movie has some racist
undertones hey
hey guys
wait oh fantastic jewelry piece huh one
down two to
go oh with what the Pearl he said he
said the Pearl I didn't hear he said out
loud at the Pearl he did I just he just
thought he was jacking her Jewel no I
didn't even yeah I was like wait and
then when he pulled it off I was like oh
right we're we're looking for a pearl I
had forgotten what we were doing no D
dude this plot is very very busy yeah
I'm back
though going to Nashville Tennessee
where to sing like
this uh wake up
dude keep your hoof on the pedal if
you're tired you pull over people let's
St
yeah good idea oh my
God we're in high
school why does that look so awesome
this is a crappy motel and you put some
lights on a tree next to christas motel
it's
Tennessee whatever it looks amazing he
he's back in the pool he's healing he's
resting I guarantee you this is a shot
from before and they're like we're just
going to use it again some Motel pool
yeah this Motel pool looks nice
all right so let's recap Percy Jackson
son of Poseidon people are hunting him
cuz he's got Bolt and he's going to find
three pearls to go to hades's girlfriend
or wife to tell them he didn't steal any
lightning steal anything so he get his
mom back so we can get his mom back from
the Satan guy with the hor and we also
got to like fight Zeus I think in the
end lady who turned to stone she yeah
because Zeus he has to convince Zeus yes
yes oh my God and he can heal and he can
heal save your woman I feel like he
would have discovered some of this by
accident like with his mom and at home
just like some of this water is not a
distant property I agree but maybe he
just like why do our parents hate each
other they both wanted to be Patron God
of Athens the people chose Athena and um
our parents have hated each other ever
since what's your mom like I don't know
she's a real will
be don't any Gods see their kids it's
forbidden right after we were born Ze
decreed that the gods couldn't have
physical contact with their mortal
Offspring damn I think my mother speaks
to me sometimes in times of trouble I
hear her voice she's crazy just like his
dad that's happened to me yeah that's
your father talking him yo because he's
a God and he can these two actors have
the ugliest eyes don't they
terrible I hate looking at
him you're on TV surrounding the missing
boyy oh now he's a famous guy too he
just gets everything Mr ugliano talk to
me about your son Percy Jackson no he's
not my son he's stepson he did not come
from these loins loins oh he cried to
kill me and he threw his mother on the
ground and his friend that looks
cool is it cake or a can shut up Gabe
now I'm a fugitive Gabe's always running
his mouth he's just mad because I busted
him up with my crutches yeah go kill him
now he sucks I can't pee with her
watching
me uh oh God Stoner oh yeah you're going
to have to come on guys let's hit the
road before Homeland Security shows
up come on guys I really hope they get
like government and Homeland Security
involved just to make this plot even
more crazy even crazier yeah now they
have a government official hunting them
down I want to know where Percy sleeps I
want to know where he eats I want to
know where he shits in nature
nature complete replica of the paron in
Nashville let's go get the
Pearl I love that he's got is two
friends with him to deliver more
Exposition and backstory about Gods it's
great that way nobody gets lost and that
way we never have any real character
development with
them so Percy Jackson be like what why
huh oh dude it's your mom say hello it's
your mom wonder if she really looks like
that she Longs for her check this out
it's 30 ft in the air and this place is
filled with tourists I got an idea P
Percy knows everything we fill this
building with water I swim up and get
it oh hey I got my worst
toilets you got it your toilet sh I got
my toilet sh just felt like toilets you
guarantee you they didn't use them the
the entire time I wanted to see her
reaction being like what is this
invention by
Humanity okay so what are we going to
do what's the plan here I got this you
got one who who Hey listen you're going
to kill the janitors chill those are
working class
Americans what is it do just put him to
sleep yeah okay and apparently every
time someone makes a sound it doesn't
alert the other people they're not dead
they're unconscious now we have 30
minutes come on cool cool I feel like
the second I heard my coworker go ah I
would turn around turn around what
happened they didn't get that pickup
shot Greg they forgot Luke how do you
turn on the shoes tell Percy's got to
break into a run okay he's got to build
up speed kind of like a a jet on a
Runway okay I totally forgot he had
these shoes yeah me too I was
like cool
awesome hold on little grab right there
oh yeah
yeah oh no no no no cowards never
mind come on Percy he's got
[Music]
it Pearl number two I got it see you
later Nashville there you go man for
first job he only had like a 10-second
hiccup Percy Jackson yet again he's
Priceless excellent at everything he do
oh
man did they all wake up where are the
other people who were knocked out I
think they're possessed got it we've
been expecting you Mr Jackson just give
us the lightning bolt and we'll let you
go I don't have the lightning
bolt okay this is
bad
what okay this is weird editing man I
love it yo it's
cool oh my God it's like a multi-headed
dragon
serpent hyra hyra oh Hydra oh yes they
fought it in
Hercules and it's a common mythological
creature I should have put together no
now we're never leaving
tum she's won hundreds of batt Game of
Thrones you got a sweet tooth
right how this Hydra is just not
snatching them up I have no
idea I know I'm like why aren't they
just eating
them wow whoa all
right oh my God Percy you're EX excent
at everything you do stop
no you can't
K don't their heads grow back yeah why
was she telling him to stop so
feverishly I just killed killed it you
only made it worse yeah it grows back
Percy when you cut off one Hydra head
two more grow
back well well well also why aren you
guys running to grab the Pearl like
right now when they were partially dead
I do like the design whenever they go
like more the uh the hellish creatures
yeah I think they do like it does look
like weird fleshy morphing going
on come on Percy get
it get it and get
out I need water yeah turn yourself into
water real
quick
[Music]
oh he can control water now too he like
C powers on that well now he just washed
away the Pearl the Pearl was right there
ohar Place well I'm just saying the
water went over there was bound to move
but I guess
not the door
open oh yes coming back a
[Music]
smart wow the tourist and pain customers
tomorrow are going to be in for a big
surprise hey it's funny how they cut to
her before they showed us them turning
to Stone that's some great effects that
that looks
awesome how are they going to get out of
this predicament it's easy let's give
person more
Powers single storm cloud that is
expanding over much of Europe and Asia
now he's really going to have to steal
the lightning because this storm is
Raging across the globe the gods are
angry we need to get the last Pearl
where's the next location gods are never
angry here in LA are ramping 75 and
Sunny I know that's why Sarah's always
in her sweater when she comes
over oh Las Vegas why
I've been looking forward to this look
guys remember always put the eights
never the 10 okay we're not here to
gamble I don't even think you're old
enough aren't you in high school I feel
like they're like 16 there's no way
they're old enough I mean yeah they're
the definition of adult playing child
acting adult playing
[Laughter]
children how are they able to get in
here you have you can walk into a casino
and be underage I don't think you can I
feel like I think they checked your ID
and stuff no no not in Vegas you could
you could wander in to any casino you
just can't obviously drink or gamble
where would we find a green pearl in
this place I mean maybe on a cocktail
waitress or a showgirl we should start
there dude knowing how tough things are
for you you will not find it at all
they're so good it's her signature dish
oh really I don't know there's some type
of like weird illusion thing happening
here what do you mean like there's some
manip there's some manipulation happen
here
okay you don't get free in Vegas no
you shouldn't eat it what's wrong with
you guys it's really good no what's
wrong with you
[Music]
guys wow oh no drugs drugs drugs drugs
yeah oh they just took ecstasy this
going to turn into a very different
movie so we go the
[Music]
hangover this movie is so strange I love
it so much are they high on mushroom
having the greatest time right now this
movie is so
weird guys why don't we stay here for a
while that sounds like an amazing idea I
mean they have to be a specific type of
food that can affect the gods let's
never leave let's stay
here
God
my poker face P Poker
Face hey man
what the hell is going
on okay that you wouldn't be able to do
as a kid no they're they're in some like
weird illusion yeah okay all right
they're falling for something they're
tra here I believe you
not this movie has to have by has dance
moves eat the
flow it DS the senses it say that's his
dad don't eat the flow keeps you
prisoner uh hey I think I'm going to go
get some a I'll be right back the flower
is what keeps you prisoner around
Focus French Connection huh good movie
never seen it you seen it yet yeah yeah
I think so on DVD what's DVD seriously
whatever I think it's the best movie of
the year wait this year yeah this year
1971 God he's just been trapped in time
there the whole time
cool he wake
up are all these people just trapped oh
yeah they're all from different
prisoners eating Lotus oh this is a
really fun sequence this is my favorite
sequence of the whole
movie what that easy
why see seeing things I really don't
want another lotus flower so please
leave me alone is there a problem Mr
Jackson Yo No thank you Percy Jackson's
awake okay whoa what are you doing with
that don't eat that what we have to go
now what are you doing we're having so
much fun no no no no we're not having
fun I don't know I would I would just
give into the illusion both of you need
to wake up now look at me look at me
you're in a trance okay we're trapped
listen to me you eat the flowers you're
never going to want to leave okay we'll
be stuck here forever oh that's amazing
though but the place looks great it's
like heaven what's wrong with that
nothing I mean yeah this place looks
amazing why
leave
they want freedom of
will
[Music]
cool oh good thing he was right there
yeah good thing he was right
there
table
get cool they get to drive in a Maserati
I want to buy a Maserati now they're
coming
Zoom go go this actually feels like a
commercial for a
[Music]
masera you will never want to leave now
that all makes sense what that was the
lair of the Lotus Eaters they've been
luring people into their traps since
ancient times what's wrong with it
though yeah I don't understand like I
don't understand what the negative
consequences other than you get to just
have a great time for the rest of your
life for the rest of your life tomorrow
is the 21st we were in there for 5 days
our deadline is tomorrow at midnight
well good thing you have all the pearls
apparently you don't age there either no
you're always hot and dressed up
forever listen Hollywood all right
they're coming
here wo to all depraved Souls hello I'm
a depraved Soul how come she doesn't
have a fake
disability well we never saw her in the
real world we only saw her at training
camp right yeah but she should like she
should have one she should have like a
broken arm or something or like like her
breast weigh her down or something you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah something
that like a teenage boy would
write or a 33y old
[Laughter]
man oh this a cool set there ain't no
turning back now yeah looks like we're
stuck in here yeah don't worry Percy I
have faith you can k out of any
situation you're ever you always do he's
really Unstoppable he really is who's
that creepy guy with a hoodie oh boy who
is that creepy guy let's fun out what
happened to the Medusa head did we
forget it no it's in the backpack or
something who are you we need to see
Hades he plays death in Supernatural the
living are not permitted here die and
come back oh watch this yo my friend
what
up hilarious I got a few dead people you
might recognize Jackson Grant and who's
joining the party Benjamin Franklin yeah
you like that don't you why would he
care about cash there you
go yeah why would we care about that he
doesn't need your money he lives in a
tomb drma the
drma
coins climb aboard damn per from that
Fountain Percy is smarter thanks for
telling me man you burning money we in a
recession shut up couldn't give I wish
the girl the girl was the one that found
them she should have been like try these
right giving our friends more agency
like no let Percy figure this one out
he's known about this for like 36
hours
awesome this is that's an awesome
special the underworld of human
misery lost hopes and
dreams wishes is that never came true
when they go dark it's really Embraces
something pretty cool yeah they do that
like the dark and the Mysteries and the
Monsters really well in this film all
lives end in suffering and
tragedy wait what's the next part of the
plot we got to get to hades's wife yeah
and then we have to stomp on the
pearls
now this looks like a really fun set to
be a part of good job production design
team I agree
what that thing what are we going to do
this like frog
monsters who who were those things hell
hounds Rosario
dawsona they send the presence of
another animal oh great you smell goat a
Seder I haven't had a Seder yeah dude
yeah
pan oh hey okay don't ignore me or what
what will you do I'm already in hell I
don't think I've ever seen Rosario
Dawson so uh aggressive
volumous heart heart he meant heart
heart
heart we have visitors cool
gar Steve cougan
welcome you have your father's looks
this came out in like 2010 but every the
entire style is like out of like a '90s
like black leather movie yeah you're
right you're Hades yes I didn't expect
you to look like this man would you
prefer that I looked like
this cool it's pretty awesome look look
look SP to the m Jagger thing it works
for
you this is cheaper you're very brave
coming here I can see the look of
disgust in your eyes but this existence
was not of my choosing looker disgust
he's got the same smolder all the time
he's either bewildered or
smoldering my only chance of getting out
of this place defeat my brothers and
take control of Olympus of course um
I'll need the bolt and I need my mother
then we have an understanding you give
me the bolt and I'll give you your
mother give me my mom first let me see
her let me see I'm not the Lightning
Thief I don't have the B give me the
bolt or say goodbye to your
mother no
[Music]
uh-oh I feel like pan is going to do
something to help
out
finally per wait was the lightning there
the lightning in the thingy oh my God he
had the bolt wait where'd he get the
shield from that guy the blonde guy the
blonde guy had the blonde guy that we
all we called it he was too nice the
whole time so of course he stole the
lightning bolt he planted it on
Percy Zeus's Master B oh maybe the
blonde guy's the son of Zeus I don't
know how that got there there not even
my shield Luke rigged it he put the bolt
in his shield and used
us that was that is way too heavy-handed
of exposition somebody somebody could
have said something
those deliveries were not I didn't
believe
[Applause]
it whoa we had a deal all right you have
the bullets let us go summon the HS dude
panie do
something yeah I could It Go as like
Supernatural Terror I feel like this
when Chris Columbus actually had an
interest in making this everything else
feels like do what you did in Harry
Potter sort
of
go give it back
Troublemaker
who oh that was
quick why'd you do that he's cruel and
abusive the only thing I look forward to
is my allotted time away from this hell
hole she helped out who would have
thought see I think the same thing my
allotted time away from this hell hole
is what I look forward to a war of the
Gods would put an end to that and I'd be
alone with only him take the bolt and
your mother she helped you called it
dude I like her look in this
movie only three what there's supposed
to be more each Pearl transports only a
single person the mom make the mom stay
Bye Mom no Junior protector might turn
into senior protector earn your horns
yeah he'll do it I'm staying because I'm
the protector just go it's my duty he's
now a senior I I'll take very good care
of him oh yeah I I'd volunteer to stay
yeah obviously I mean it's Rosario
[Music]
Dawson
bye oh my goodness no no oh my God is
Olympus just the top of this
building man
what's this building maybe what's this
iconic building in New York is that the
Chrysler I don't know buildings I don't
know buildings the Chrysler Building I
know the names of build there the Empire
State Building and then there's the
Chrysler Building is Chrysler in New
York I don't know Zeus and beside him
preparing for battle this isn't Olympus
this is this is the Empire State
Building Percy the entrance to Olympus
is there you
what well you weren't supposed to make
it out alive who would have thought he
was a traitor not us you hid the boat in
my shield why well when you said you
were going to the underworld it hit me
that is the perfect opportunity to get
the bolt to Hades why would you do that
to bring Olympus crumbling down well
it's too late cuz I'm returning the bolt
to Zeus right now why would you do that
not before
[Music]
midnight wow these wire effects are
phenomenal over 100 Battles let's go why
do you want to war the gods they've been
Empower for too long I say it's time for
our generation to take over a world of
new Heroes you're no hero
[Music]
no you
missed oh you missed again it's hard to
hit them when they're so far away is it
is that you're a yeah I mean he's
obviously those that's three three
strikes you're at you you you should
just lose the the bolt immediately now
that rubble's probably affecting all
those citizens down
below whoa that's pretty
cool you got this
Percy now the guy's not afraid of
heights at all
oh my God Percy's found his
equal
[Music]
awesome he's flying he can fly they can
fly they got the they got the the feet
thingy the wings oh right hey why can he
fly cuz they both have it oh right he
had tons of you guys
sorry he just can fly so straight all of
the sudden before he was
like he's Percy Jackson he's learned I
get
it
no no summon water or something you're
surrounded by water
everywhere you really think that would
have been a lot worse
hey you put that down maybe they were
wrong maybe you're no son of posidon the
actor's real accent um started coming
through they
here summon
water show you where the son of Poseidon
cool oh there was a just happened to be
a water
tank hey there's no such thing as
coincidence in this
universe
now would be a good chance to strike him
with some lightning okay yep a little
late
okay rise
Percy dude not not a not a single drip
of water on Percy Jackson he managed to
stay completely dry I am so hungry I
you're right you Tera asked me before
filming if I should grab some water I
should have done it you should have done
it sorry I then effed
up
yeah I think I am the son of
[Music]
sidon that
line he is just he says I think he is
just too perfect at everything man he's
like everything I want to
be it feels like a teenage boy imagined
himself as Percy Jackson and got
everything he wanted
yeah so much
gold where he's going to go see Zeus now
I guess so to give him back the
lightning bolt I said we don't talk
about this movie when it's done we
immediately start the
sequel kill
me
hey you're a wizard Harry it is almost
midnight this was predestined you wanted
this battle you have only yourself to
blame let irrational war is not the
answer answer great accent time has run
out wait sequel
oh is not the answer
Papa
[Music]
wow oh oh they're massive my name is
Percy Jackson and I think you might be
looking for this I have your lightning
boat I wonder if they hear their voices
like hi my name is Percy
Jackson give me the bolt Lightning
Thief
cool you're wise to betray your father I
didn't steal it and I have no connection
to Poseidon and who did Luke son of
Hermes you know Luke he was angry at you
all of you he wanted you to destroy
yourselves cuz you ain't been around hi
Mom I am so proud of you I have a good
friend he's a Sader named Grover he's my
protector and the only reason why we
escape the underworld is because he
stayed
behind and now you expect me to bring
him back very
well yeah he went through hell to get
you a goddamn lightning bolt I'm not
expecting you to forgive me but I want
you to know that I'm grateful I didn't
do it for you I did it to save
Mom see you later
dad
whoa we don't have much time oh he's
small now
how old was I when you left 7 months
look I didn't need you there all the
time I would have liked to have seen you
just once why didn't you ever come back
you know yeah like through the sink or
through the bathtub or like I'm
showering just show up yeah when I was
with you and your mother I became less
concerned with my responsibilities what
are your responsibilities I was becoming
human oh no what are your
responsibilities that's why he passed
the law preventing Gods from ever having
contact with this
children that was because of you like
when the earthquake hits and then the
wave comes but he gets in and he's like
I know I'm not the father you always
wanted but if you ever need me I'll be
there for you in the waves in your
thoughts and in your dreams that's sweet
what if he's dreaming about the daughter
of Athena that's he shows not the wet
ones just to be like Gregory you're
doing good
son you pleasure son oh God just
promised me that I don't have to see
that loser Gabe ever again I kicked him
out yeah he's gone he's out of our lives
forever can you clear my name on the
news too so I don't seem like a drug
dealing
kidnapper Bye
Mom hey dude get some new clothes so the
Conquering Hero returns Triumph Grover
hey he doesn't walk we weird he could be
wearing jeans I mean I agree but it's a
little this looks like got a huge ad
scoliosis thing here a new clone smell
good he's a a horn oh I see I've seen
him the whole time look at that thing
got a little horns in your head now see
him Protector first class baby
congratulations you're so cool Percy
Jackson left the camp disobeyed my
orders you deliberately disobeyed me but
you did good kid oh um which is why
you're my favorite student you do
nothing wrong
Percy you can receive all the training
in the world but ultimately you have to
follow your instincts then you've also
required no training to do
good I think I'd like to give it a
shot in more ways than one welcome
[Music]
home their
eyes UNC comfortable grab who who wait
first Dr of battle strategy don't ever
let your opponent distract you sexuality
always distracting
me roll
credit doesn't look choreographed at
all feels very
spontaneous yeah no they're just they're
looping around with sword they're just
doing a thing cuz they knew they were
going to do a drone shot and they're
like nobody really pay attention to what
we're doing over here
Canada and it's
[Music]
over if I could stand without leaving
the frame I
would screw
it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it
weird go I'm not doing it yeah that you
need you need the sticks for okay you
can't just whip on jeans and people not
go like what's going on there
okay let's look up if there's a post
credit scene before um uh oh that's
frozen that
happens before we stick around for all
this does Percy Jackson
and the
Olympians the
Lightning Thief
have
open the
door open up answered oh my God he's
like related Delux yes this guy so
here's your junk you can let yourself
out how am I supposed to move all this
stuff by myself deal with it yeah girl
slam that door in his face she has
agency she's like panie I need a beer
get it
yourself do
not oh yay he's is going to die now it's
like by
lightning nice I wanted him to Die the
whole time I love that it
[Music]
happened I love that he died and he was
turned to
stone Percy Jackson killed
him oh
there I do wish they would have given
Athena's daughter hold on hey reject
Nation you know running real rejects is
an incredible journey something I am
truly grateful for but I got to be real
with you for one second here managing
the business side especially taxes to
put it lightly is incredibly
overwhelming it's like navigating a maze
without a map and that's where our
sponsor rocket money comes in a sponsor
when approached I was so excited to work
with because I kid you not just last
month I started using rocket money cuz I
needed to sort out this financial puzzle
and honestly it's been quite eye opening
not just for taxes but boy oh boy that
whole cliche of this app is true I
discovered apps and subscriptions I have
been paying for that I had not used in
ages it is like finding out you've been
leaving lights on in a room that you
never use so yes rocket money isn't just
another app it's like a freaking
Financial Guardian Angel it finds and
cancels this forgotten subscriptions
monitors your spending and even battles
to lower your bills thank God it's as if
they're personally invested in saving
your hard-earned money like I try I
really try to be on top of my expenses
but rocket money they show me blind
spots with a simple tab I can cancel
unnecessary subscriptions they even
handle the hassle of negotiating with
customer services a relief my goodness
to put it into perspective rocket money
has helped over 5 million users save an
average of $720 a year that's more than
just numbers it's a piece of mind so I
invite you my fellow Rejects and taking
control of your finances so go ahead
visit rocket money.com rejects once
again that's rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
rocket
money.com rejects I really do stand by
this app thank you for partnering with
us so as many of you guys know most of
my days are a couple of hours of filming
and then most of the time it's dedicated
to like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often accumulating to like
10 to 12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life's biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and getting healthier has
been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimony and that is of course
for hello fresh and hellofresh is in
just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your healthc
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hello fresh I'm
looking forward to hosting holiday
dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best
part the variety it is incredible I'm
pescatarian so they have these delicious
meals just like dejon onion crunch Simon
over lemon broccoli spaghetti and from
my more plant-based days the vegan Maple
carrot power bowls they aren't just
meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long
day the last thing I want to do is spend
a while cooking and that's where
hellofresh is 15minute meals are a
lifesaver they're quick nutritious and
Oho tasty perfect for my non-stop
lifestyle so why not join me in making
this holiday season both health
conscious and delicious with hellofresh
with over 45 recipes and seasonal
add-ons to choose from every week
there's always something new to try and
here's something to cheer about go to
hellofresh.com reject free and use code
reject free for free breakfast for life
is that accurate that sounds way too
good to be true there's no way that can
be true go to hellofresh.com
reject free and use code rejects free
for free breakfast for Life One
breakfast item per box as long as your
subscription is active tag your
hellofresh trations with # hellofresh
piic and at hellofresh and let's cook up
some fun and healthiness reject Nation
remember it's America's number one meal
kit I do wish they would have given
Athena's daughter more stuff to do give
the girl stuff cuz the goat guy he got
some stuff he got to like protect him
and whatnot but really thought she was
going to get more of a role in saving
him cuz I think that have just been cool
she did when she was up in the Chrysler
Building whatever like slightly EMP
State Building the Empire State Building
you got Chrysler in my head because you
said it five times it's not my fault
it's his now listen I'm going I'm going
to just throw I'm going to throw
categories your way go ahead I'm going
help you out here action what do you
think of the
action I like the the action I did I
I when you say action I'm like I have to
go through all of like the action stuff
uh and we already discussed how when it
gets like dark and Moody and there's
like the Satan figures which is mainly
when the action happens that uh that
it's awesome that it looks cool I like
it it's cool right I'm into it I like
when that stuff happens but what I what
I didn't like I honestly I think that it
all looked really it looked great and I
thought all the action is good and I
like the special effects he didn't like
the Medusa thing I was like I think
those look real and weird I was I was
down with it I mean from up close not so
much but from when she was further away
I was like oh gross um sure yeah okay
I'll give you that okay uh but the yeah
the exposition did drive me crazy and
after a while it was weird there's a
couple parts in this where these are
good actors that they'll say a line and
I'm like yeah no one said hold on I
don't believe that let's go back let's
settle you're you say this line and
let's hopefully we believe you and
there's a few parts where I that digs
under my skin I hate it I do not like it
when I don't believe an actor for the
rest of the time I did believe him yeah
yeah I'll meet you on all those points
I'll meet you on all those points action
was fine not the problem is is that
there's no real like Stakes so there's
no real intensity it's more like oh this
is like fun action but the movie has
such a fast pace that you're like ah
screw it whatever I'm on board I'll
watch it it's it's action yeah and yeah
the visual effects were real up and down
for me sometimes they look great and
other other times it looked really like
fake like I thought the dragon looked
great the Satan guy when he was like
fire that looked cool and also this is
an older movie so I I I do have that
understanding that it's an older film so
it's not going to look as up to par the
goat and the centaurs looked good uh
some of that Pier BR and stuff though
you didn't think sometimes weird when he
walked that one time when he was walking
where I was like he's trying to sell it
too much or they told him that I don't
know I didn't know what they were doing
um yeah I think the visual effects can
be a little bit wonky but most of the
time it looked actually all right and
and then she talked about that uh what
you think of p and yeah to your point
about the acting um yeah I mean usually
if every cuz I've seen I've seen most of
these people in other movies where they
do great job yeah at everyone here no
one's no one's great in this movie all
right like no one's great here um the
most believable one is the abusive
husband Joe
pantell he's the most believable one
great and Zeus did a great job but he's
only in two seconds of this movie yeah
the way you would expect them to use
Zeus where as you build them up in your
franchise like everyone is reasonably
Charming I
suppose um and it it usually comes down
to like overall direction I'm I'm under
the impression here's the impression I'm
under that Chris
Columbus yeah let's let's confirm like
cuz what year is this is he in between
Harry Potter movies at this point after
like a couple Harry Potters that that
it's like h fine I'll do it you know
that's kind of the impression that I
have of there's like not okay
2001 uh okay I think he did Chamber of
Secrets which was the last one he did if
I'm not mistaken yes he did Chamber of
Secrets okay and then he eventually
comes back and does like this fantasy
movie which has ear it's not exactly
Harry Potter but there's some
similarities you could totally draw
action sequences the way the camera who
lives amongst the normal life an abusive
household like there's a lot of a lot of
similarities um but I'm under the
impression that they were
like yeah we liked what you do with
Harry Potter and he didn't really he he
did it for the paycheck I I got a real
like hey let's get the guy did Harry
Potter to do his thing and he there's
like a not a real passion behind the
camera for this and I get the sense of
that and I I there because it's a bit
messy it's it's
truncated and it's kind of moving out of
whiplash pace
and um yeah there's a lot of like flat
dialogue but I I I'd be so lying to you
guys if I said that I I did not have fun
I so had fun watching this and I know
book readers hate this movie so I'm not
trying to appease anyone here he doesn't
read I don't read I'm I'm dyslexic which
is apparently a gift yeah he can read
great ADHD is a and you know there is an
argument to made for that ADHD is a
blessing and a curse so I know all about
it yeah I've been diagnosed with it and
um and other things as well and and I
could say that oh it's I could totally
see how it's actually helped get me
places in life this movie has a weird
commentary about it I don't quite get
what they're saying it's I don't either
or like maybe ADH or this dyslexia and
then you're like oh are you just trying
to say it is what I just said a blessing
and a curse well a lot of things don't
have time to breathe or like simmer in
it get it point across right no we're
just we're on to the next thing it's
just move move move move with a bunch of
like really good actors in here yeah um
oh it's only two writers I thought it'd
be like way more
writers only
two um I like Logan lurman he's really
he's Charming oh yeah I I love him I
mean I love him from Love and monster so
much I love that movie um and that's
mainly why what I know from but uh in
this yeah that there're both I think all
three of them I mean especially her um
she's in another thing they're all good
actors it's just there are certain
points in this where they're two times
with each actor they've set a line and
I've gone did nobody stop to think we're
not going to use that take that they
need to say it like we believe it it was
weird I was like did we maybe they ran
out of time they're like you get one
take and then it sucked I don't know
um but as a whole they didn't suck and I
did have fun it's good actors in here
just those things really can eat me
alive yeah yeah you know like I I like
like I've read the some of the Harry
Potter books and then watching the
movies I was like oh these are actually
these are pretty good adaptations from
from book to film they're pretty good
adaptations and I have no idea what the
book is like I didn't even know the
story at all right like does he win in
the book too every time or does he go
through some more trials and tribulation
there's like no Stakes when it comes to
Percy Jackson but you you get the
impression watching this that they went
how do we take this book and condense it
into the save the cat movie structure
that's exactly you could tell you could
feel the Hollywood uh mechanics behind
it yeah without even reading a book I'm
like yeah I can completely see how they
have tried taking and putting it
into like their basic Hollywood outline
this is like akin to when people say a
movie feels like algorithm made and this
feels algorithm made of like I bet
there's a much stronger Source material
out there because holy the way the
script moves this is like this it is it
is totally all over the place there is
no real emotional depth that has no time
to let situations breathe to Warren
Stakes it is one of those movies where
everything is constantly being um washed
over by H whatever Exposition and I'm
having fun yeah that's that's that's the
film but I just get so mad at that it
wasn't just like multiple things of I
mean yes it wasn't just a few things of
exposition it was a lot almost every
time they were met with a new
circumstance they had to say it out loud
why they were there or remind us what
they were doing oh yeah they like idiots
I'm like yeah but can't we give those
characters a different line that says
something about them and their like
moral code as to why they're there but
we didn't do that and so yeah there were
no Stakes as big Stakes but there also
weren't really any individual Stakes
either except for like we all got Daddy
problems and hi Mom hi Dad once we got
there and yeah he got his horns at the
end but like there's information
there's yeah there's info there's just
not we didn't play with it enough and we
didn't give the characters any dialogue
to EXP explore that information that was
like we have daddy issues and it was
like instead of exposition we could have
pulled away to have a conversation of
like well this is bugging me you
probably have the same problem here's
how we Bond and now we're going to be
able to fight this thing better because
we bonded or whatever but that didn't
happen that's all right that's all right
you know I my I'm here to direct the
next one if you want that's all right
that's all right I'll give some notes
book readers who have seen the I haven't
even seen the TR for the Disney Plus
show but apparently like it the the
author of I I heard the author of this
movie like walked out of the theater or
like cried at how terrible it was
something like that at this movie yeah
just of how like un Unfaithful how they
Dam terrible cuz to me I'm like no this
feels like another run ofe Mill you know
youth fantasy movie where the kids are
played by adults and and there's like
really wooden direction and you slap in
a a cat cast full an ensemble full of
famous actors who don't really have
there's like no reason to get famous
like you don't need Rosario Dawson you
don't need Uma Thurman no they barely
bring anything to the role because
there's nothing really in the script
them
chew you just you do it for marketing
purposes it's one of those things yeah
you know and uh so to me it's like
another one of run middle of a ya novel
brought to life um but there is like a
Whimsy and just a fast-paced about this
that allows it to be a bit of a Breeze
despite how predictable it is like it's
one of those things where I should hate
this movie but I don't no and I'm not
trying to satisfy anyone we don't care
we knew we knew people didn't like pitch
we knew people love pitch black we got
so much crap and we're like we don't
like this movie and this movie is one of
those where I'm like I feel like I
shouldn't like it and I don't know if I
do but I had fun I had fun too like I'm
not going to watch it again if someone
was like going while I'd be like no I
don't need to do that um but in this
format of reactions yes it's it makes
for an enjoyable like filming a reaction
yeah yeah I agree a good time yeah
that's where we're at we're at good
times right we we had fun we like it we
love you uh you got last words before I
close this puppy out uh no I think we
talked about uh oh my gosh apple and
Spotify if you're listening is too late
to addit it in it's too late too dang it
but I'm also you know what I am too I'm
a sucker for like myth whenever you
throwing like weird mythological
I'm I'm a sucker for you love it yeah
even though I don't know it like I don't
actually know it whenever I see ear
marks of it or anything like oh Medusa
or whatever it it feels like the like
like a Hollywood studio Cinematic
Universe thing that I'm just like yeah
it's cheesy but whatever I'm having fun
it's cool cuz we don't see it enough
yeah it's just God thing we don't get
that a lot yeah yeah just have it all
thrown in there is is fun cuz it's got
this uh it's 2000s but it's it's got
this like weird Middle Ground of '90s
and 2000 you know that '90s leather
thing that happen thing with Uma and
with Steve right that they're in full
leather or like then the dudes show up
and they're like I'm Zeus in the modern
world like you guys seem like you're out
of a 90s movie yeah um that that that
look but from like Matrix to Charlie's
Angels era you know where they all have
that look and that's what they have here
is that look they got a look anyway I'm
done I'm done they got a look he's done
leave a like leave a comment tell us how
cool we are don't forget to subscribe um
you guys know the deal if you're not on
patreon get on it I don't know what else
I say at the end he's throwing coasters
around this is a terrible environment
save me from it okay we love you so much
we'll see you on the next
one all right John pick a name all right
here we go here we go let's do adilia
Chamberlain Adelia Chamberlain do you
know what you're getting for Christmas
it's good this year you are going to get
a pencil oh you could do a lot with that
a pencil that is not sharpened so
endless potenti you're going to have a
little
Adventure where you're going to see the
magic of what it's like to sharpen a
pencil because let's face it no one does
it anymore man they don't they don't
need to they're obsolete now it's either
a pen you can't find or a keyboard of
sorts or that goes on a screen that you
can't find exactly now you're going to R
you're going to use it to ReDiscover the
child within you who sharpens pencils
anymore and it won't be an electric
sharper which are which are really the
fun ones when you
just it comes out a sharp or the cranky
one you know that's that's the one
you're going to get you're going to get
the cranky one yeah and good luck
telling if it's going to be one of the
ones that has that real satisfying nice
grinder or if it's one of the messed up
ones but you only get one pencil and and
you know sometimes in those cranky ones
they don't turn out so great sometimes
you got to go for a while and they Gore
up your tip and they really mess it up
so if if you botch that one pencil
that's on you man sorry
that's on you it's on all of us imagine
if you if you sharpen the perfect pencil
and what do you do with that pencil you
take it to a piece of paper again a
piece of Parliament that no one really
has anymore but if you're able to take
it to that paper and you start writing
your novel using that creative brain of
yours scribble
away and then what happens you'll have
to resharpen that pencil that sweet
sweet pencil because let's face it the
more you use it the smaller it's going
to get and then you're going to have to
get more paper and then before you know
it maybe
about two hours in you're going to go
this would have been more efficient if I
just typed this I see why people are
moving ahead with technology after all
I've given to Greg and John at the
patreon page yeah they give me a
pencil what is this some kind of
insult yeah yeah you need be put in your
place that's again yeah but you know
congratulations yeah the number two
pencil hey it's a classic though all
right it is John was obsessed with
mechanical pencils in school I was I
thought they were the bee's knees and
now look at me now I love a good wood
pencil I know yeah we're always using
pencils always around the office I'm
like don't bring me any ink don't bring
me that computer give signing checkbooks
and
pencils yeah yeah don't worry man I'll
fix I'll fix any smudges you might
happen to make on that you know it's my
honor but um in all seriousness uh I
hope you enjoy that pencil it's a good
one there's so much you can do feed all
your creative endeavors and I'll
serious uh I hope that I know Christmas
time gathered with the
family where there's uh political views
flying left and right A lot it can be a
lot to discern the two and having to
mediate and just be content with the
immediate situation I understand how
tough that can be where you got to
your way through its family
just just smile I get it i' I'm
there all the time I hope they're
watching so they know what I deal with
but that's why a pencil comes in handy
cuz you can take yourself away their ass
that's right you can kill every one of
them and people are going to be
impressed no matter what like they're
not going to investigate you cuz people
are going to be like you did that with a
pencil how bad teach me that is intense
yeah for YouTube disclaimer we are
joking we are not actually encouraging
the harm of others HT behaviors sharpen
pencil even if it would be a a good even
though it would be pretty interesting
pretty fun to try out you know movies
like something about that like so like
if you're I've hurt myself on a pencil
before you know weird you're like it's a
pencil yeah it's such an innocuous item
and yet you could do such damage yeah
and they Splinter when they break all
kinds of stuff or like uh or have you
ever hurt yourself on a
quill it's almost impossible but it can
be done it can be done especially if you
get one of those fancy metal tippet
ones pointy as
hell which is the best writing tool to
do some damage with chat gbt
bab the the machine is mightier than the
pen is mightier than the
sword love you Adelia Merry Christmas I
hope Santa comes down that shelf
exhausted going why didn't you clear the
fireplace and then reaches into that
back pulls out of bed and then it
burns all this H to give you this for
this I check my list enough time to the
pencil at your face I hope you're happy
to hell with you I'm walking out the
door I wasted 70 seconds on this house
it's a kid waiting for something I don't
know I could have just thrown the pencil
down here going to just dropped this and
hoped you find it gone off and continue
delivering
ps5s Merry
[Music]
Christmas